well i hear that you're actually a fan
of the pickle of the month club is this
true
i have my my membership card and
everything yeah okay well i would like
to play a game with you okay it's time
for in a pickle
okay we're gonna um eat some sour
pickles while i ask you some questions
are you ready for it i hope so all right
first pickle we're going sour okay okay
ready all right
oh what about the crowd stop listening
to and why
broadway song
um
oh man uh i haven't watched well no i um
i watched oliver the other day
i haven't seen that in a while and um
so something from that i don't know i
also like rent yeah of course
hamilton's always on richard i mean sure
hamilton but that's kind of cliche all
right take another bite okay you're
obsessed with mud lurking what is that
well um there's something i think you
would really dig really yeah so mud
larking i just stumbled on it on on like
youtube
um it's like these people they they a
lot of it happens in london and you know
the the thames and and so they they like
walk along the thames river and and they
find artifacts from medieval times from
roman times and and uh you know old
coins stuff like that and that's mud
lurking all right next pickle it's a hot
and spicy one okay take a bite
what what's the last lie you told
um
i love this pickle
oh
that is spicy though yeah no actually
it's not bad
it's actually really good take another
bite all right
well
anywhere in the world where would it be
right now
um
i'd love to go to australia
um
new zealand that whole area yeah tokyo
would be cool i mean there's a lot of
places i haven't been to that you know
everywhere you named is absolute
perfection and if anyone has the
opportunity to go i highly recommend it
okay finally chocolate covered pickle
this is the first for me do i have to
well you know you never know
all right let's ready one two three
you're stranded on an island and you can
only take one thing with you what is it
not this
um
well do people make like this
is this something you guys bought
[Music]
i'm so sick
[Applause]
oh no it would be good chocolate and
pickles we did not make this this we
bought all right well i'm going back to
the original um i have to say
i didn't like it at first
but it's kind of growing on me
um
can i bring a boat
well that would be very resourceful why
not you get one thing
um okay will you please give us one
teaser
about what we get to expect on this
glorious exciting season of the
marvelous mrs move
um
i will take your pickles sir
i i mean uh
um
it's funny it's like it's really funny
it's it's i think it's the funniest
season so far i mean that's really yeah
i think that's the only thing i'm
allowed to say
i got an email and it like it had bullet
points of like and it was just basically
like you can't say anything so i will
say that i really firmly believe that
this is the funniest season so far well
i know everyone's gonna be very excited
for it and michael i just i love you
endlessly i love you in everything that
you do you are the best actor you are
such a good person
a try
you succeed you're such a good egg vegan
i love you michael vegan for more head
to bananamores on the drewberrymart
show.com where mitzi bananamore visit
him on the set of maisel to the button
club where joel um joel
is actually the proprietor the
proprietor you'll understand it when you
see it um and the new season of the
marvelous mrs maisel premieres on
february 18th
[Music]
you